[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at sonos i i know i've
talked about this before but i have had
sonos for so many years sonos speakers
uh the whole setup at my house before
sonos was even a sponsor and i just love
them and i kept asking can so must be a
sponsor can sonos be a sponsor and
finally
they are a sponsor share the joy of
listening on sonos this season make the
sound system on your wish list a reality
with speakers and sound bars that are
easy to set up i mean so easy guys i do
this
easy to use and they all work together
so you can listen in any or every room
and bring the family together with
incredible sound for everything from
classic carols to festive films sonos
works with all your streaming services
and control is simple with the sonos app
your voice using amazon alexa or google
assistant and apple airplay 2. spoil the
listeners in your life with a gift that
keeps on giving treat gamers and movie
lovers to an immersive home theater
experience with beam keep your fitness
loving friends motivated with great
sound for their workouts
in their workout playlists with move and
help relatives relax with hands-free
control of their music and more on sonos
1. uh i just love having the party mode
on so wherever anyone goes in my house
they could be listening to the song
that's playing i also have a song for
just chill nights where i can go
downstairs and just chill music or go
upstairs for some barometer
music some seinfeld music
some seinfeld music um outside for party
mode whatever you want to do sonos is so
easy you don't need these bulky speakers
or amps or all these things
sonos makes it so easy i wish you can
come to my house right now and see all
the goodies that i have
so uh put sonos on your holiday wish
list uh they are fantastic and it's easy
just go to sonos
s-o-n-o-s-com to learn more and wrap up
your holiday shopping you're listening
to inside of you with michael rosenbaum
ryan tears is here hola it's so exciting
to have you with me yes
it seems like it's been a while it has
been we pre-recorded a couple we did we
did we did some pre-recording
i hope you're uh look thanks for
listening thanks for uh
making our show a a choice
in your
choices
we're not good with words anymore no
we're not good with words it's uh it was
a long weekend but uh i really
appreciate it i appreciate you listening
and tuning in we've had some really
great episodes and people have been
writing in and uh i appreciate you
writing in and telling us what you think
of the show um
make sure you give a review
email your friends tell everyone to
listen
the handles if you want to follow us on
the instagram and the facebook are at
insideeapodcast
and on twitter at insideyoupod
reviews are wonderful
and uh spreading the word spreading the
gospel
thank you to all my patrons out there
who uh give back to the show and uh
they're a real big part of why the show
is still going
and ryan's a big part of why it's still
going i love having ryan with me and uh
thanks to jason my editor and bryce my
producer and cumulus radio for uh
believing in the podcast uh we've got a
great episode today
um
rayne wilson he's back and rayne you
know he's got this podcast metaphysical
milkshake with oslin
and it's uh it's great it really makes
you question
or think think of the questions of life
of you know why we're here and what
we're doing and uh i just uh i i love
having rain on the show because he's
such a bright guy
and he's so friendly i get intimidated
sometimes when people that are a lot
smarter than me are on the podcast and
so i was like well what are we going to
talk about and at the end i felt like
hey you know it worked out and i got to
remember to tell myself that you know
hey you could do this you're
interviewing people you're you can do
this man
but i try to have good conversations
with people and it was easy to have a
conversation with him did you enjoy it
it was good you were afraid of getting
deep and you went there and it was fine
we got a little water was fine the water
was fine tasted great it's great um like
a milkshake hey i'm gonna be at la
comicon december 4th and 5th and we're
doing a smallville nights in l.a tom
welling and i so get your tickets for la
comicon the fourth and fifth the fourth
is the big smallville nights we've
already sold a lot of tickets it's an
intimate evening we read scenes with
fans i put on a bald cap it's pretty
funny and uh we have a blast doing that
i hope you're having a
marvelous week and i hope you have a
great thanksgiving
i mean happy thanksgiving to everybody
out there uh let's be thankful and
grateful and all that stuff in between
um
but without further ado why don't we get
into the amazing
um
rain wilson it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you pulled up in the car and i go look
at you you look refreshed and you went
oh
yeah what is that what was that
you were one of these guys like myself
that you're hard on yourself aren't you
sure i'm hard on myself i think probably
most of your listeners are
angst ridden hard on themselves
complicated individuals sure because you
because you are and we are yeah
um refreshed is ha it's hard i um i'll
be honest with you um a good friend of
mine uh died last night
how do you like that i don't like it
yeah you know it's really [ __ ] if i
may say f on the show you're asking
yourself for permission to say [ __ ] on
your own if it's okay with you
[ __ ] yeah you might he might not be one
of those guys that want to say the
f-bomb on the show ryan say it just so
we feel better [ __ ] there it is is ryan
the news is he like sidekick he's he's
my engineer and he chirps in here and
there you know he takes notes and he's
uh he's uh he's seen this as his portal
to to fame i think he's already famous
no you're supposed to skyrocket me to
super start on that yeah that was
exactly what i wanted to do he said it's
still the plan ryan he's banking on lex
luthor he's better looking than
you are jesus he threw out the lex
luther did you hear that i did that
he's better looking than you are but he
is he's very lex luthor or ryan
ryan ryan ryan is better looking than i
am you know
first of all i'm incredibly sorry but
like the last time you came here the
night before your dog died
wow
this is this is probably the last time
you're gonna do this podcast
the next time i do it
just call me after someone
maybe after you die yeah
maybe i'll die right here in your
podcast that would be ratings would go
up this is getting very macabre very
fast but um uh i did a film uh two years
ago two and a half years ago called
black bird
that no one saw i like all of the films
that i do uh with um
susan sarandon and kate winslet among
others wow and uh roger michelle was the
director he's who passed away and uh he
did notting hill he did this movie venus
with peter o'toole and he's done a lot
of
just terrific film changing lanes i
think with bennett
um he's got a new one coming out uh
called the duke it's a british film
he's just a classy how old
63 something like that see this is what
scares me was it was it
just it just happened heart attack yeah
yeah i don't know any details of that
other than that so
but you know way too young and he was a
really special dude i mean he was just
kind insightful sensitive uh
you know devoted collaborative
smart as hell really wickedly wickedly
funny
um so
it's a bummer i'm sorry yeah
how do you deal with i mean how do you
deal with death i mean is it something
that just you think about all the time
you think oh i'm i'm in my 50s now
uh it's you know
don't date me here
well
uh you know just did you print out my
wikipedia page no i just i wrote some
things down that i probably won't even
even discuss you know
can can ryan finish the interview please
ryan tell me about how rain feels about
death
no i mean can he interview me yes right
just be me and ryan they'd ask him that
first question yeah how do you feel
about death brain
thanks ryan um i'll tell you this has
been the year of death for me i'm sorry
to get all crazy this is where to do it
this is where to do it yeah i'm i i'm uh
yeah
this is been the year my father died 13
months ago
and then i lost two friends to cancer
during this last year and now you know
roger passed away and he was we were
friends but it's not like we were like
hung out all the time or anything like
that but my other two friends were very
very close to me
and
no one from covet i don't know anyone
who's passed from covet i mean i've
heard of friends of friends and
relatives and whatnot but
uh
uh i um
yeah so it's been a lot of death this
year i feel the same way i you know in
the last year and a half i lost my
grandfather was my best friend i lost my
sister i lost my uh dog irv
uh
your sister my sister might have a half
sister okay my dad's uh second marriage
and uh she was sick for a long time and
she passed away
and it's just been one thing after
another and um
you know
i i think oh you know you're doing all
right you know but i don't deal with
things well i sort of bottle them up or
i just hide them away and they come out
they manifest themselves in different
ways and then they come out
and uh come out sideways yeah i mean how
do you do i mean were you close with
your father
um
you're gonna make me cry well you're
gonna make me cry well you know i mean i
cry
i've cried on this podcast people have
cried on this podcast have they really
yeah or you could just say [ __ ] off i'm
not gonna answer them have you cried on
this podcast me not yet no
no but there has been bobby lee you know
the comedian i know he cried on here
about his father's death
jennifer love hewitt cried on the
podcast yeah it's not something i just i
urge people to cry i just you know i try
to like get inside of what if love was
everyone's middle name
bobby lovely rain love wilson mike
michael love rosenbaum
that'd be ironic for me i think
because you've never known love i've
never loved myself
rain
that's hysterical
um so yeah i think so last time i don't
know when i was on two three years ago
sometime i was on your podcast had a
great time loved it still get people who
are like i love you inside of you bro
you got a nice uh a nice loyal following
out there and
um
we we got deep i remember and we talked
a little bit about spirituality faith my
family etc and
yeah my dad and i like most fathers and
sons we had a very complicated
relationship so
my mom took off when i was two years old
so i went and stayed with my dad so my
dad was the only kind of i didn't really
see my mom again from between 2 and 15.
usually it's the mom the dad that takes
off right yeah so opposite for me and
then
so he was the only constant through my
life i didn't have any siblings he was
tried and true he always was very
supportive of me being
an artist being an actor
um
you know he was always there for me
at the same time he was very
he had had such a traumatic childhood
himself he was really completely cut off
from his emotions
so i didn't get
the
the warmth the hugs the nurturing
um
the
i didn't get kind of listening to the
essentials the essentials i feel the
same way that's oh my god it's like uh
so he's there he was there but he wasn't
really there so i really loved him and
yet there was always this kind of
disconnect now
truth be told he really tried hard in
the last like three to four years before
he passed and he was 79 when he died
we had gone through a lot together and
healed a lot together and
so there was there was even greater
intimacy so believe it or not even in
his late 70s there was a great
more uh
expression of love between the two of us
so how do you do that though
when not having that connection not
having that bond for your
90 95 of your life with a man how does
that start was something you started did
you or did he reach out or
um you know because that's that's a hard
thing to start
start up so late in life
like some kind of bond or him trying i
feel like i've done that too with my
father i wrote him this letter that was
passionate but it was also very hard on
him and just saying hey [ __ ] you've got
this wonderful kid out in los angeles
and you could have so much fun with and
you [ __ ] on it and you know it took time
and then he started to come out of his
shell a little bit and was nicer and
trying harder and trying harder with my
family my grandfather when he was sick
with alzheimer's
but
um you know it took me writing a letter
that was just like almost like a [ __ ]
you letter
yeah
and
but it wasn't easy and i didn't think it
would happen it was almost like every
day i'm like oh he's being nice today
how long is this gonna last
you know but uh how did that start for
you we had we had some ups and downs and
we had some letters we had some angry
letters go back and forth a lot of it
for me was through my work in therapy um
and uh sorry to sound like a cliche but
you know that old phrase like
don't go to the hardware store for milk
and
i kept going to the hardware store for
milk in terms of kept going to my dad
for a kind of love he was incapable of
giving me so once i was able to kind of
really deeply do that work and get out
my resentments and my hurt and my trauma
that i had experienced vis-a-vis him
and just accepted him
uh on a deeper level i think most of the
work was actually mind to do not really
his to do because
he he was trying in his own way and it
might have been very limited but i did
see him making an attempt to connect and
and and have more of a heart
little things little things little
connection and
and so then i had to stop being like you
know
he's never gonna meet my needs my
unmutable needs are never gonna be met
by my dad i'm never gonna get that hug
that is like
rain you matter you are incredible i see
you
um
uh he would say i'm proud of you like
i'm so proud of you all your acting work
and all you were great in that movie and
i i loved it and it's good work in that
like so he was supportive that's cool so
that's good but never like
really like how are you son how are you
what is going on with you in your soul i
want how
let's you know is this this is this is
my relationship with my father this is
therapy for me this is exactly right
it's like you know why don't you bring
your your dad on the phone oh my god no
no no no no no why don't you let me
interview him oh boy on a special inside
of you yeah wilson interviews
harvey rosenbaum listen i know all about
your relationship because i lived with
my father mark that's my dad and i could
just see you talking to my father he
would be completely closed off and
freaked out
he doesn't you know he's again when you
were saying uh i've never heard the word
you know i love you
he said it once in that letter like if
you ever don't think i love you read
this letter or something like that but
never i love you proud of you uh
really how are you doing like i think he
just says it to say it and then like
okay good but how you doing
i could say anything i could say i just
took a [ __ ] okay great so
it's not really deep it's just very
everything's always been surfaced and
for me to try and
think it's gonna get any more than that
i'm crazy it makes me a crazy person
because it's just not to happen it's not
in him and it's me wanting something
that's just never going to happen so i
feel like there's a similarity there
would he ever go to a therapy with you
no i don't think so i mean you might
want to try one one of the things i did
i was going through this was a while ago
now 10 years ago i was going through a
really dark time and i went through this
intensive therapy program
um
and
then
i went back and i brought both my
parents i brought my dad and my mom to
do some work with me just each one for
like two or three days like three or
four sessions so it wasn't like
20 12 hours a day or something like that
but it was intense
and did you cry
i did cry yeah yeah i cried a lot and in
front of your father
sure i've never cried in front of my
father you know i feel like that would
just be i i couldn't do it that's why
you should let me interview him i'll cry
in front of your father
i can't imagine like you
i'm sure this has been said by many
people out there listening but i can't
imagine my father going to therapy with
me it just wouldn't happen he wouldn't
open up his story it's one of those
things where his story is completely
different well did he go through a lot
of let me just jump in and say did he go
through a lot of trauma or does he come
from generations of closed off men
closed off man my grandfather's pretty
closed off but
incredibly loving to his grandkids there
was no not a better man to me
and a role model than my grandfather and
i think that kind of probably bothered
him
at the same time it he liked that i had
a relationship with his father but uh it
was closed off and you know i remember
him saying something was like well you
know i was hit
i go you were abused no but i got
spanked
i go okay you know i got hit he goes oh
i never hit you i go dad
seriously are you telling me that i
never was hit
and he just threw it away
anyway what i was trying to say is he
didn't want to talk about that didn't
want to go there yet no he has a def
very different memory
and um well i'll give it to my dad for
for showing up to that because that was
he never liked therapy he never trusted
therapy he always said like psychology
was a soft science and it was you know
he he viewed psychology and
and
consulting what you know what what is
that called um you know let me say that
again he he viewed you know therapy as
essentially the same as like
rainbow crystal meditation and essential
oils you know what i mean like it just
was all in this
new age and
nothing against new age even but he just
viewed it all as this kind of poppycock
so for him to come
uh meant a lot and he was trying to make
those little steps so i i will stay
grateful about that so there's so many
of my needs were not met and yet super
grateful for what he was able to give
and did yeah this that that the
tip-toeing steps he took toward me over
the course of his and your mom was in
there too
um i think there's like one or two
sessions where they were together so
that was weird so my birth mother who
left when i was two
and my dad
both in their mid 70s
early 70s and
um but then i had
some and then mostly kind of separate
with them because it wasn't much
to talk to to them but um
yeah and uh boy there's a lot more i'd
like to say but i still have parents and
relatives that are still alive and i
can't i can't completely go there dark
[ __ ] yeah some darker stuff yeah
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at sonos i i know i've
talked about this before but i have had
sonos for so many years sonos speakers
uh the whole setup at my house before
sonos was even a sponsor and i just
loved them and i kept asking can so must
be a sponsor can sonos be a sponsor and
finally
they are a sponsor share the joy of
listening on sonos this season make the
sound system on your wish list a reality
with speakers and sound bars that are
easy to set up i mean so easy guys i do
this
easy to use and they all work together
so you can listen in any or every room
and bring the family together with
incredible sound for everything from
classic carols to festive films sonos
works with all your streaming services
and control is simple with the sonos app
your voice using amazon alexa or google
assistant and apple airplay 2.
spoil the listeners in your life with a
gift that keeps on giving treat gamers
and movie lovers to an immersive home
theater experience with beam keep your
fitness loving friends motivated with
great sound for their workouts in their
workout playlists with move and help
relatives relax with hands-free control
of their music and more on sonos one
i just love having the party mode on
so wherever anyone goes in my house they
could be listening to the the song
that's playing i also have uh a song for
just chill nights where i can go
downstairs and just chill music or go
upstairs for some baron
music some seinfeld music
some seinfeld music um outside for party
mode whatever you want to do sonos is so
easy you don't need these bulky speakers
or amps or all these things
sonos makes it so easy i wish you can
come to my house right now and see all
the goodies that i have
so uh
put sonos on your holiday wishlist uh
they are fantastic and it's easy just go
to sonos s-o-n-o-s-com
to learn more and wrap up your holiday
shopping inside of you is brought to you
by geico
hey
it's geico folks
i do love my geico oh do you oh yes i do
love geico you know uh whether your rent
or uh
own your home
we've got so much crap around you know
the holidays and all these things to do
it's like why do you want to
pay your homeowners to one person and a
renters to another your auto policy to
another
make it easy with geico and they have
this wonderful thing called ryan a
bundling policy that's correct
it's a bundling policy
bundling policies with geico
it's a good thing we're already busy we
have so much to do around our home and
it's easy here's all you do you go to
geico.com g-e-i-c-o if you don't know
how to spell it geico.com you get a
quote and you see how much you can save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's
geico.com even a rosenbaum can do it
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy boy i can't tell you how
much this works i get emails all the
time thank you for talking about better
help thank you for getting me into to
therapy
ryan does better help i do i just you
know uh i just had a friend this morning
i was facetiming with him and his wife
said you know my kid's uh dealing with
depression and uh do you know any good
therapist i go oh better help online
therapy because they're in the middle of
sort of nowhere and you don't need to go
anywhere you can facetime or text or you
know it's it's better help is just uh
it's amazing it's it just helped you out
yeah it's uh it's convenient
it's convenient yeah it has been good i
have gotten a lot out of it well i like
that look whether you're struggling with
grief relationships or stress or having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you
better help is secure online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with a licensed
professional
therapists better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
accredited therapist you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
you don't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room
therapists have a broad range of
expertise which may not be available in
your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime folks
send a message to your therapist you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
you need and that may happen you know
you meet someone the first time you may
not vibe with them you change a
therapist better help it's that easy
and i i completely recommend this so
many people have told me it works
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy by a landslide if you
ask me and financial aid is available
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join over the two million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help ryan
that they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states
inside of you is sponsored by betterhelp
and our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside give it a shot
better help
you know you know last time we talked i
remember we talked about the office
briefly we didn't really get into the
office because you know everybody knows
a lot about the office it's like you
know you know we don't have to talk
about everybody loves the office you
were loved your loved character
but i remember you saying something
pretty profound you're like i was a bit
of a a dick or i was maybe a little hard
at a certain point on that show
and do you think cause i look at the
podcast now and
and soul pancake
which
you know founded soul pancakes to create
a space where people from all walks of
life could discuss and question what it
means to be human
and do you think that there was
something that happened to you maybe
while filming in the office or the way
you were or the way you felt like you
were that you needed to change so you
started doing things like metaphysical
milkshake which we'll talk about all
these spiritual things and getting in
the baha'i faith
faith and things like that do you think
that is it did it start kind of back
then or or soon after
it's kind of finding yourself who you
are
well you know
part of it is you know i i don't want to
i don't want to be like mr hollywood
recovery guy and there's a whole bunch
of people talking about that but i am in
recovery i have experience with the 12
steps and i've had
you know
issues with alcohol in the in the
distant past and so for me it's part of
that process so it's it's like
um
powerlessness and unmanageability
um around stuff and that goes hand in
hand with ego narcissism and entitlement
of being an addict and then all of a
sudden you add fame and throw fame into
that mix right your character defects
swell up and
flare up and whatnot and at the same
time i'm trying to
you know connect with my higher power
and you know become more spiritual and
more grounded in my spiritual life and
trying to be a better person sometimes
succeeding sometimes not so it's it's
like this what i'm describing is like
all of us you don't have to be an addict
to be going through this this is what
this is what we do we have battles with
our ego and we have
times when we're we're trying to make
ourselves and the world a better place
so it's it's part of this struggle but i
will say that
those early years of the office
especially like 2006 2009 right in there
like
there was i was all of i went from this
unemployed character actor to all of a
sudden being like completely
recognizable in this huge tv celebrity
and and then was getting leads in a lot
of films and getting offered a lot of
stuff and and money and all we were
always broke my wife and i and all of it
so
that will inflate your ego and your
narcissism too it was it was a
tremendous challenge so soul pancake the
digital media company which has now kind
of been subsumed by participant media
which is an even larger uh media company
was part of my yeah it's part of my
attempt to kind of
understand myself and other people what
it means to be a human being that we're
all on a philosophical journey we're on
a psychological journey uh we're on a
spiritual journey you know on an
artistic journey yeah and
and metaphysical milkshake the the
podcast that we're doing is kind of born
out of that and that
that whole process
is it one thing or many things that you
do
a process like a daily process like if
your ego gets in the way are you aware
of it you go rain that's your ego and i
have this tool to say that this is your
ego and that's not where you should be
coming from do you have certain tools
that you use so when something's
something arises that you don't like
about yourself or you're upset about
something that's a great question and
basically
you know how if you have diabetes you
might have like an ins you have to like
prick your blood or you wear a band or
something and it monitors like your
blood sugar level or your heart
rate or blood pressure or whatever
insulin levels etc like there's that
monitoring like
i have to do
a daily monitoring of myself
for on a number of different levels
every day
every day i have to monitor
it's it's not intensive i just kind of
several times a day i just have to take
a few deep breaths and check in with
myself where's my anxiety
because i've had an anxiety diagnosed
anxiety disorder you too high five yes
um i wish i didn't high five you on that
one um i know
and i've i've had depression
uh in the past and very serious
depression and um
and also i have to check my
entitlement
arrogance ego
stuff as well that's one of the things i
need to be checking in on i always say
like you know what are the tools like
i have to exercise a lot and i have to
meditate
uh pretty and pray and meditate pretty
much daily in order just to get to
normal it doesn't like it doesn't make
me if i if i if i meditate for 10 or 15
minutes and pray turn things over if i'm
exercise it's not like all of a sudden
i'm like mr zen dalai lama i'm just like
operating as any normal american in los
angeles wouldn't so if i i'm operating
at a deficit if i don't do that work
right
i mean do you get anxiety attacks still
to this day
um
i would say i would i i get close i get
close most of my anxiety attacks were in
my 20s right and then i had some in my
forties but it's been a while now it's
been a leader what do you do like
besides you meditate mm-hmm you check in
with yourself
are there other things other tools that
work for you that might work for someone
else like like i wake up with anxiety i
feel
you know rain's coming over it's got to
be a good podcast i got to do this and i
you know i feel a little overwhelmed at
times or just for with little things i
think even the little things overwhelm
me would it have killed you to wear a
little bit nicer shirt what's wrong with
this one
this is a good color on me
oh you went with the color because it's
an old t-shirt you put on like an
eight-year-old
t-shirt you wore a t-shirt
yeah this is a long sleeve and it's it's
a little i think it's sexy
you know something i could use you know
rosenbaum this might help you or one of
your listeners i do this every day i
meditate for 20 minutes to this music or
to to nothing or what is it well i i
certainly i i meditate and i pray
and i act and i exercise at least five
days a week and it's not like i'm in
wicked shape but i just kind of need to
do that and
i have like one thing that really helps
very specifically is
um so human beings are wired to be
fearful
and
we're wired to be negative because
that's what kept us alive for 100 200
000 years you know if the if the bushes
are shaking over there it's like oh [ __ ]
the bushes are shaking oh there's a lion
in there so we're kind of wiring fighter
flights yeah for danger
and uh uh
you know and in socialization we're very
wary about and concerned with like
status and where we are and how we're
perceived and whatnot and
so
um
gratitude is an incredibly powerful tool
and you know there's a lot of podcasts
on gratitude and a lot of writing has
come out especially in the last
like five years but like with a group of
friends of mine we have a gratitude text
chain so every morning we send five
things that we're grateful for and it
sounds so dumb and so no i've done that
before too yeah i have i'm grateful for
you i'm grateful that uh i have a uh you
know my dog is uh with me and i'm not
alone in the house yeah it could be
anything right anything yeah i i today i
texted i'm grateful for the turkey
sandwich i had you know it's uh but it
just it that little bit of a shift that
little one percent two percent shift of
your perspective through gratitude
is a is a big help it really does help
because we can live in a pro and my
tendency is to live in a perpetual state
of
anxiety and discontent with how things
are and what my life is so if i can
shift towards gratitude
and love and serenity just even a little
bit to counterbalance that
like realizing like look i've i've got
my health and yeah a lot of people died
this year but
you know a lot didn't and yes you know
my family's still together and i get to
do cool creative work and i get to go on
the inside of you podcast and you know
there's there's wonderful there's
wonderful things i have a nice red pants
and a nice are those red gray i'm
colorblind i really didn't think they
were red yeah they're reddish they're
like brick uh brick red yeah they're
nice it's a nice fan all right thank you
yes i appreciate it so pray
meditation
uh gratitudes those are the three keys
those are some of the keys yeah you do
it before you go to bed you sit there
and close your eyes and say what i'm
grateful for before you sleep at night i
haven't done that but that is a very
good idea to do because people they have
the studies gratitude is is an
incredible tool
just google it if you're out there just
the studies on gratitude like
you you get sick less you live longer
you get more you know raises at work and
promotions at work like uh people like
you better you gain social capital
through being grateful like their
gratitude isn't it's like a wonder drug
do you say your gratitude is ryan no
you never say what you're grateful for
no i mean no not in not on this kind of
uh
yeah no it's not something i've ever
focused do you meditate no i don't
meditate either do you pray
uh nope okay so none of the three yeah
but but ryan is not as complicated as
you and i i mean no no offense i mean
he gets i'm sure you've got stuff going
on but yeah but
you seem like a piece of a lad no i'm
like a bowl of oatmeal that's uh yeah
what is that what is it that's just
pretty plain
i don't think you're that plain just
kidding but you don't think you don't
let things get to you as much
uh i mean i can let things get to me uh
but i mean i probably should be doing
these things with these gratitudes and
things because this has been a stressful
year and this is just there's just been
a lot of uh going to bed very anxious
yeah i think i need to change my ways i
think i need to make i mean i think
that's the first step is like if you're
doing the same thing expecting different
results we know what the answer is but
if i just wake up every morning and i
say my gratitudes and i pray and i
exercise and i
i'm already in the right
on the right path and you you you
guarantee me this will help in some way
guarantee me this is a hard guarantee
here yeah
sure all right
yeah i guarantee that this will make a
difference you know but i think the
other thing that we had started off
talking about um
ego
and i do think like a
in whatever way you can do it in therapy
and journaling you can do it in 12 steps
there's so many different ways to do it
just talking to a friend but just
recognizing like
when my ego perceives a threat when i'm
in my ego when i'm in
um
my
self-will
and
getting defensive prickly
and comparing myself envious all of this
stuff the stuff of ego like that needs
to be monitored you know we have to like
have like a heart monitor and be taking
the temperature of that creature and
accept it it's part of us we have egos
because we're part
chimpanzee and we want
you know we want good stuff for
ourselves and it's what's kept us alive
there's nothing evil about it but it can
dominate us and it can and it's not who
we are we are spiritual beings living a
human experience we're we're riding
around in these meat suits we get 80 90
100 years you know if you're unfortunate
like roger michelle you get 60 some
years if you're fortunate like norman
lear is 100 years old you know but
whatever it is it's a handful of decades
in the meat suit but we're luminous
radiant beings that are beyond our ego
and so i do think that there are also
spiritual tools that you can find from
so many of the spiritual traditions that
can help us
on this to navigate this church what's a
book to read that you'd say the one book
if you're just getting into this and you
just want to find some peace what's that
one book
the dhammapada by the buddha the
dhammapada by the buddha easy read
pictures easy read no pictures but
honestly an easy read the one of the
great things about the and it's
important to read like the dhammapada
don't read like buddha of the day quotes
because most of those are just made up
and in fact there's websites of like
what is what really did the buddha say
and what's just like made up because
people were just slapping stuff on like
take a deep breath and love yourself the
buddha you know they'll just like
slap up a new age quote and then
contribute it attribute it to the buddha
so but the the study in buddhism
is all about this um
this clutching grasping attachment to
ourselves to our wants to our egos to
the stuff of the world including what
we're where the milieu that we work in
in hollywood in terms of fame
um
but all this gla grasping clutching
wanting
never enough
i'm not enough comparison
um
that's all stuff of the ego and
it through some very simple perspective
shifts and exercises you can just
you can just step away from it a little
bit just kind of step outside of your
body and witness it and go oh look
there's my ego doing its thing oh bless
you ego you're trying to protect me
you're trying to take care of me i love
you but i'm not
you wow i sounded wise all of a sudden
he really did sound wise
i was just enamored i was enamored yeah
you know i have a thing where
some therapist once told me if when you
have anxiety
it's like you're in the driver's seat
and you could say hey [ __ ] you could
be back there but i'm driving
like i know you're there
but don't let it take you over you're
still in control
and and i try to i also try to stop
myself when something's happening we're
like why stop it what is the wrong right
now what can happen to you can you die
no you can't die i actually say this out
loud
have you done this before yes have you
been a success yes
why are you going in i talked to myself
is that weird do you ever do that i
don't think that's weird at all i think
whatever works i mean for me
uh i'm i'm
maybe your therapist suggestion is good
and different things work for different
people for me it's just recognition like
if i just kind of take a deep breath
rain you're really anxious
look at you oh you're worrying about
this and you're worrying about that and
you're worrying about that
oh wow
wow check that out okay
then i immediately feel better i just i
didn't change anything i just noticed
that i was anxious
it's like noticing the ego acknowledge
it acknowledging it
just just seeing it no judgment i'm not
gonna fix it i'm not gonna push it down
i'm not gonna like get over it or get
through it i'm just i'm just witnessing
it and then
then we're all of a sudden we're just
more whole like oh i see you know you
you know it's like we're not our
thoughts you know i don't know eckhart
tolle i guess for a second book besides
the dhammapada the buddha anything by
cortoli you know the power of now or a
new earth um especially his audiobooks i
love hearing his
weird austrian
gremlin accent there's like a word
rehearsal kind of feel to it it's a
little bit verna herzog he's more
extreme but but yeah eckhart tolle's
like that is only now why are you here
what no that's i'm doing it terrible but
anyway you trust me the audiobooks are
great i listen to them all the time and
sometimes i'll just i have them on my
phone and i'll if i'm feeling anxious
i'll just like
just i don't care what chapter just hit
eckhart tolle talking to me and i'm just
like ah and that's what you do in your
car a lot of times you'll listen to
these in your car instead of music
instead of thinking you just
yeah yeah yes when uh when in high
stress that's there's another tool
there's another tool eckhart tolle
audiobook's a great tool but his whole
thing is like we're not our thoughts
we're not our feelings right we have
thoughts we have feelings that's not who
we are because we are able to rise above
those and go oh look i'm having thoughts
oh look i'm having feelings so whatever
that is that consciousness
that's that's a higher consciousness
that's kind of a higher part of
ourselves that's able to just lovingly
detach just a little bit and float away
from uh all of that it seems like it's
just really acknowledging it like
okay you're stressed right now why are
you stressed okay you got this okay it's
just kind of acknowledging like this is
why you're stressed instead of freaking
out and not really taking a second to
wonder why or understand why yeah and to
accept and accept it like oh okay all
right yeah you're stressed if you're
gonna get this job or not like well of
course you are it's okay you want the
job and you'd like to make the money
from the job and you'd like
the work from the job and okay
that's good so you're stressed about it
right i love you
do you say that you say i love you buddy
i don't but maybe i should
you know one time my therapist actually
said i want you to
i want you to wake up what happens when
you wake up and i go well i have anxiety
what do you do i lie there well why do
you lie there
well i'm hoping it will go away does it
no
okay so what do you do
i lie there
i want you to get the [ __ ] up i want you
to get a drink of water
and she also said this was a while ago
she was i want you to look in the mirror
i want you to tell yourself you love you
you love yourself yeah affirmations that
was boy that was hard because i was
actually i remember the first time i was
actually trying to be cool about it like
i'm the only one in the [ __ ] room and
i'm like
love you dude
you know i'm like come on
hey dude love you finger guns you're
[ __ ] you're awesome yeah i was like
you know
it's very hard that's one thing i'm
learning how to do is just like kind of
accept myself love myself for all my
faults and
that is the hardest i think there when i
was first getting therapy my therapist
did the same thing i had a he gave me a
sheet of affirmations
um
and there were all these like i love you
you're very good at this
anyways the first one on the list was
i am enough
and
at the time in my life when i started
saying that
i would almost cry
just saying those three words like
looking in the mirror and going i am
enough it was so hard
because i would immediately just be like
no you're not you [ __ ] idiot you're
not exactly
so that's where i would jump to so to
just kind of be like
i am enough like even now like saying it
it feels weird and i'm like no i'm not
i'm not i need to do more in order to be
enough
right right yeah jesus
inside of you is brought to you by
brooke linen even if you can't put a
price on comfort a sale definitely
doesn't hurt brooke lennon's biggest
sale of the year is here and bringing
serious savings on everything you need
to keep cozy and this sale is big news
for your comfort brooklyn's entire site
of super soft seriously cozy essentials
is on sale right now brooklyn was
created to bring dreamy comfort to every
corner of your space if price is so
affordable they may make you pinch
yourself shopping doesn't get any easier
than brooklyn bundles save more when you
stock up on essentials for your space
now's the time to get gifting with deals
on items for everyone on your list
whether you're shopping cents for a
candle lover or grabbing a gift card aka
the gift that keeps on giving this kind
of comfort is always a hit for holiday
brooklyn's comfort game is unmatched and
their lineup keeps getting better
five-star sheets were just the start and
their collection of cozy must-haves now
includes everything from dreamy decor to
their newly launched slippers i'll tell
you ryan i have the most comfortable
uh sheets that you could possibly lay in
do you say lay in or lion
unclear but it sounds comfortable both
are comfortable uh truthfully um when i
got brooklyn and they the sponsors
always they usually if they're kind
enough they will send you something they
sent me sheets and i'm like i'll give
them a shot
as comfortable as i've ever felt in a
sheet for sure
brook linen is just wonderful uh i've
heard from many people i mean this is a
name that i think you've heard of before
um you got to give these guys a shot
guys do not miss out brooklyn's biggest
sale of the year is here listening after
the sale you can still save visit
brookelinen.com and use promo code
inside for 20 off with a minimum
purchase of 100
that's brookelinen.com
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
promo code inside it's all about comfort
for the holidays brooklyn is there for
you inside of you is brought to you by
m1 finance there's a reason they call m1
finance the finance super app this
all-in-one app makes it easy as pie to
invest
borrow and spend exactly how you want
build a portfolio of stocks or etfs in
minutes with their intuitive pies
interface or use a pre-build expert pie
that invests according to your goals
investing involves risk and m1 helps you
invest according to your risk tolerance
borrow against your portfolio
with some of the lowest rates on the
market then use it however you want keep
in mind borrowing increases your risk
and rates may vary or stash your cash in
their free digital checking account it's
fast it's easy and it saves you tons of
time and time
is money switch to a sleeker easier and
better way to manage your money plus get
thirty dollar bonus to your m1 invest
account when you get approved and fund
it with one thousand dollars within your
first 14 days and it's easy you just go
to m1finance.com
inside of you for more info that's m as
in michael
m the number one
finance.com
m1finance.com
inside of you terms and conditions apply
uh all right this is a good segue into
metaphysical milkshake okay
because i watched an episode and
you know
talk to me about it talk to me how
briefly how it got started with with you
and reza aslan
and how these two minds came to be and
and and to make this show that and a
show that you both wanted to make
because i think it's it's very important
ultimately it's like
what is our life why are we here what's
the purpose what's like all answering
all these questions and you can't really
answer all them i guess the best of your
ability but why did you do this
um
so
i started about 11 or 12 years ago a
media company called soul pancake that
was a digital media company it existed
mostly most people know it as a very
successful youtube channel with three or
four million subscribers we had shows
like kid president my last days
the science of happiness lots of that
were viral videos that people posted all
over facebook and whatnot so my first
iteration of that was called
metaphysical milkshake that's what i
originally wanted to call it because
i've just always been interested in the
metaphysical questions about being a
human being and being alive why are we
here
what happens when we die what is what is
our purpose but beyond that like what is
time and uh
you know do we have free will and you
know so many metaphysical questions that
intersect with psychology spirituality
philosophy
creativity on a lot of different fronts
sociology
and
so soul pancake went in its direction it
did its thing i had a show on soul
pancake for a short amount of time
called metaphysical milkshake where i
interviewed people in your bus in the
back of my van yeah in the back of your
van um
that was fun because i always liked the
name and then
i knew reza aslan's work and we had
bumped into each other at a couple
events and we were having breakfast
actually not far from here uh in the
hollywood hills and um
you know we were just talking about life
and
we're like god this our conversation
should just be a podcast and him and i
really have the similar um interests in
terms of the topics that we want to
discuss
and that started the process of us you
know starting this podcast
life's big questions what it means to be
a human being you know because i i feel
like our our country is so divided
uh people are at each other's throats
there's so much there's this mental
health epidemic with young people going
on that is uh
really
it's tragic it's horrible
the anxiety depression suicidal ideation
you read the statistics around
kids you know it used to be the
statistic that always has blown my mind
the most is um
uh
all since they since they since the they
started doing any kind of studies at all
about psychology the loneliest
generation was always senior citizens
because a lot of they're in old folks
homes and whatnot or they're put out to
pasture whether they're living alone or
whatever that was always the loneliest
generation this shifted about eight
years ago the loneliest generation
became
high school and college kids the
loneliest generation guess what that
synced up
with smartphones
and instagram and social media there's
other factors but those are those are
two it's a disconnect it is a disconnect
they're not they are feeling seemingly
connected because you have instagram oh
look someone liked me i have 287
instagram friends it's like they're not
your friends how many of them are really
your friends four three zero you know
yeah
so
any who we just felt like these
discussions are really important like
we're trying not to make them academic
we try and like make them accessible to
everyone um but there's something that
red state folks blue state folks
everyone in between has something in
common yeah it's a it's like it's the
human experience it's what we were
dealing with you know in as with our
shamans as cavemen and what we're
dealing with in ancient greece and you
know through the through the renaissance
and then college campuses it
stoned out of your mind at 2 a.m like
these kind of discussions uh they can
unite us they can bring us together and
i hear like when i when i listen uh you
know you have people call in and ask
questions and like what what's the
purpose of life and you know what
happened before the big bang theory
which i think you let reza take the
initiative on that one
that's that's a tough question because i
always think about that i'm like well
before the big bank there well who
created god well then if we keep going
who no one created anybody but there has
to be something but if there's something
but if there was no time if the big bang
created time
then there was no time before the big
bang so there was no before
the big bang because that's what you're
saying you can't measure
you know right years or like
what's the one question that you always
are asked and you don't really truly
have the answer for
um
boy that's a good question what is the
question
asked a lot i don't really have an
answer for um
um
well you know an old an oldie but goodie
is um
uh what uh you know
is there a god you know and prove
there's a god or that old discussion you
know which
frankly is a boring discussion to me and
and
you're never gonna change any mind
anyone's mind by kind of
making a series of salient points about
whether there is a god or isn't a god
like it
it works on a deeper level but that
that's one of the tough ones to always
engage with i mean i have
my answer i i'm very secure in that but
that that's a biggie you know
you look it up on youtube there's
you know there's those debates that's
endless are and have them millions and
millions of views people are very
interested in those they're usually have
their minds made up so they're going in
like yeah atheism or yay atheism
team theist team atheist yeah you said
something
about
it was something interesting on one of
the episodes where i mean not that you
don't say anything interesting in other
episodes but you said something about
you know people say well if there's a
god why is all there this evil and this
death and all these things and i think
your response was well i don't know but
what if we just all live in a utopia
where nobody stubbed their toe and
everyone was perfect and everyone was
like isn't that just as bad in a way
yeah and it just made it was just really
smart the way you uh you
and that's that that is there's an
interesting thing where there's this
common argument among atheists like well
if there is a god why is there so much
suffering in the world and that's an
ancient question it's like well
so what would that look like so does
that mean that if there's an all-loving
god that then there is a world in which
there is no pain
because there's no not a world where
anyone gets cancer it's not a world is
there death in that world or if there is
death it's always peaceful and it's in
your sleep but you can't break your arm
because
isn't pain
difficulty
anguish
challenges tests isn't that really the
meat of being alive isn't that what
being alive is kind of all about and
speaking of the dhammapada the buddha
says life is suffering this is one of
the four noble truths that you know life
is is suffering
so maybe we suffer for a reason we
suffer to grow it's like when you work
out when you're doing bench presses not
that i would know anything about that
but when you know you're tearing the
muscle fibers to build muscle right when
you break your bone
it heals itself by becoming by
making more bone material it's broken it
becomes stronger than it ever was so
you know there's a lot of analogies that
lead in that direction you uh you
interviewed larry king on
the in the van in the van yeah and i
love this
it was just like i mean i think he even
smacked him on the ass
[Laughter]
you knew him well
i just met him that day
yeah you didn't yeah he did you met him
that day and i spanked him on the ass he
seemed like he was your best friend well
i think i had done it was like a it was
like a
give and take thing i went and did larry
king's show right and then he came in
the van and i did an interview well you
asked him these questions and i thought
i kind of want to hear rain answer these
questions that he asked
larry king
define happiness in 10 words or less
this is i'm on the spot right now this
is it i mean you asked larry king then
okay
happiness in 10 words or less um
connection
nature
art
community
you're counting right
oh my god this is good though you've
already four those are big ones i mean
smoothies smoothies are probably
somewhere there yeah somewhere in there
and someone that way there's a few more
what
by the way those are things i wouldn't
have thought it like that if you would
ask me anything like i would have
thought you wanted me to put a sentence
together happiness is well when we i
know but i was trying to be but that was
a better way of doing it yes because
those are important things what drains
your soul what recharges it what drains
my soul is looking at my phone um what
recharges my phone
hey
hello what recharges my phone is my
charger by my bed well actually i don't
have it by my bed i moved in the hallway
because i don't want my phone by my
[ __ ] bed you know what i mean do you
honestly keep your phone outside
like outside of your room i keep my
phone outside my room i bought a [ __ ]
alarm clock
because i don't want to i don't want to
be reliant so there's a tool
reduce anxiety i don't want to wake up
and just look at my phone wake up in the
bling bling bling bling the emails and
oh [ __ ] right i forgot to write that
person back oh god i got a calling right
ah that sucks so uh what recharges it is
um is really uh
nature and and connection i really think
it's all about i use that word
connection but i think that
the answer is always in connection you
know whatever the question is the answer
is in connection and that can be
with your
spouse or partner um you know that can
be with your with your family or with
friends
or or a group
but
we thrive in community with one another
and i think we
we wallow in solitude
can you relate i can relate i think i
can relate
easily
what what's the biggest question you
wrestle with
i guess my biggest question was like am
i am i doing the right thing now am i
spending am i
putting my
my energy
in the right direction am i am i doing
the right thing what is there something
else i should be doing
something like that
i feel like that too i always feel like
what is it that i'm supposed to be doing
i wish somebody could just tell me like
i almost wish i was just good at one
thing not to brag and say i'm great at a
lot of things but if i was just good at
one thing then i'd have no choice i'd
have to do that
um
purpose i i i don't even i i wrestle
with that all the times like what's your
purpose
you know try to be a good person try to
give back try to help those that are in
need try to
um
but do something that makes you feel
good altruistically you know what i mean
yeah and i i don't i still am unsure of
my purpose
maybe my purpose i'm already living my
purpose doing this podcast helping
people maybe that's part of my purpose i
don't know there's got to be something
bigger what's yours do you feel like you
have purpose
well
yeah i mean i think this is
where
i think where this is where god comes
into and i think the main issue with god
is that how people define god so if you
define god as like
a daddy
man male figure who's powerful kind of
gazing down on us and it's like ryan was
good today michael was bad today
that kind of god i'm not talking about
but if i if you're talking about like
the you know the the
the creative power of the cosmos that is
within us and without us and flows
through everything and
uh
gives a kind of greater purpose and our
souls are connected to that so our
bodies will drop away but we'll continue
into some other plane of existence
onwards toward this all-powerful
you know cosmic energy so
if
when i feel
good is when i feel aligned with that
energy whatever that is i it's
obviously it's hard to describe but it's
more of a feeling than anything else but
i i liken it like to a sailboat where
like you want to get over to catalina
but the wind's blowing that way so you
have to kind of tack
but but you kind of like if you feel the
wind in your sails
then maybe you're headed in the right
direction and that's it's a it's an
ineffable thing the wind and the cosmic
wind in your sails so
i try and be in that like is it does
this feel like
i'm being taken in some kind of right
direction you know so one of the things
i'm doing right now is i'm writing a
book on spirituality which is obviously
a passion of mine
and
which is a weird thing for a
comedic character actor from a sitcom to
be writing a book on spirituality might
be the first time ever but it feels
right it feels like oh this is a good
thing this is something i should be
doing now
this is uh that's great uh so that does
feel good my wife and i have a
non-profit in haiti called lee day haiti
that educates girls in rural haiti when
i do the work on that i
you know i [ __ ] myself out as dwight
like i do these in fact there's a thing
on prizeo.com right now where i i'm
going to give an office tour through the
san fernando valley of like our
locations oh yeah i saw that on
instagram right yeah i just i just
posted it uh today it just launched um
and
and then i take all that money and then
i give it over to these programs that
are educating girls who can't read you
know essentially so that gives you
purpose that feels good it just feels
good it's like i'm never gonna be like
if i do something like cameo or
something like that i'll take that i'll
i'll do i'll do those annoying videos
but i'm going to send the money off to
so those are some things but like
career-wise as an actor i don't know
you know do you love it as much as you
used to i don't i know that's what
happened to me i feel like uh you know
i'm gonna do this movie and maybe do
this but
i there's something about it that just
doesn't interest me as much anymore like
i'm saying yeah
what are you doing do you really love it
i totally wrote who are you doing it for
i totally right are you doing it for
money and because people think you're
really good at it is that the reason
you're doing it yeah
i i don't know i'm kind of lost in that
sense i i don't know exactly what you
know what i want how are you feeling
about that yeah i i
100 relate you know
the way i put it is like as soon as i
discovered acting at like 16 which by
the way and i think we talked about this
on the last time i was on the show
i could be wrong but i vaguely have a
memory of it
i did it for the girls
of course so i moved to a new high
school they had a great acting program
and i auditioned and got in this acting
class and then i did this acting
exercise and i made everyone laugh and i
was the new kid in the school
and the these cute girls came up and
like oh my god you're so funny in that
where are you from you're from seattle
oh will you sit at our lunch table you
know and hang out with us and oh are you
going to audition for the play and i was
just like
you know just
okay you did it for the women
there was no art there was no like i
must express myself
i'm in the ancient tradition of the
shamanic storytellers
[Laughter]
no it was like oh my god this girl's i
was before that i was on the chess team
i was i was so nerdy and
in the orchestra and like all of a
sudden these doors open so that started
me on my journey but
from 16 when i started and then into
college and doing plays then grad school
for acting and doing theater in new york
and then coming to la and then doing
wallowing away for a few years then
getting on the office et cetera
like i just lived breathed acting
anything like i want to act i want to
play characters i want to get cast i got
to move my career forward i really want
i'm hungry to just be acting sometimes
it'll pay sometimes it won't it doesn't
matter i just i need to be acting then
it got caught up a little more with ego
like
well i should be getting this movie and
why aren't i not getting this
opportunity and i should be doing x y
and z and why am i not
but but i feel the same as you though
something in the last three four years
i'm just like
yeah i like acting you know i just went
and did this project it was fun you know
and it's great the people were great but
it's like and then it was done i was
like okay you know um
i mean i'll keep doing it it it it pays
good and it's fun and it's nice to be
around you know smart funny people and
being on the set can be really fun but i
don't really have a desire to be on a tv
show for years and being on the set you
know 12 14 hours a day
uh for years you know i don't i don't
fortunately i don't have to do that but
yeah it's right it's a shift it is a
shift so what do you think scares me so
where do you think that's going to take
you would it so obviously you're a
successful
podcaster podcaster and you know i'm
writing a lot so i'm you know i have
some
projects we're pitching and things you
know i like to write and um it's not to
say that i don't want to act just like
it just feels like something was lost i
used to have that drive that you talk
about i used to have that drive where i
just always wanted to be the center of
attention i always wanted to be on set i
always wanted to kill it crush it the
producers to be so happy and my agents
to be making money and everybody to just
be and i'm like yeah yeah yeah and then
i'm like
well you're still a miserable [ __ ]
what's happening there what's going on
there you really enjoy and it's not to
say i didn't have any fun i just i don't
i i'm trying to figure that out and by
trying to figure it out i'm going to do
it again
and i'm going to continue and see how i
feel and really see if there's still
something there because there isn't some
people just love to be on set all day
and just love to do it over and over and
over and over again and i something was
lost i just feel like wow we have to do
a six-hour scene now we have to do this
same scene for six hours it just is not
appealing as as look i'm blessed i'm i
thank god i was on i did some work and i
made some money and things would be
different if i if i hadn't i'd be still
doing whatever i could
but now that i have that choice at least
for now there's part of me that's just
uncertain about where that future lies
with with acting yeah um like i said i'm
going to do it i'm going to do a movie
here coming up but like you said it's
just not that
[ __ ] yeah yeah feeling totally all right
uh metaphysical milkshake where could
they find that by the way
anywhere you get podcasts anywhere you
get podcasts yeah we um
we're trying to put out an episode a
week which is hard but uh guys it's
really great it really is it you know i
have a short attention span and just
hearing these guys talk about life and
hearing people's questions and just
talking about all the things that we
think about is just so
uh so interesting so interesting and i
think you guys are really gonna love it
metaphysical theory you're very kind
thanks we just did we just dropped an
episode with jason isabel the the singer
songwriter do you know him yeah and uh
it was about what is music
and
just kind of like trying to really sum
up like where does music come from like
what what makes music music like that
that trying to get to that spark of
creativity why are why do humans have
music
why are why don't we just live without
music like what what evolutionary
purpose did music in our lives
serve do you know what i mean like if
you're a
bf skinner behaviorist like music makes
zero sense it doesn't keep the species
alive doesn't propagate the species
right i guess you could say well some
birds sing because they're it's a mating
dance so like it creates joy frank
pleasure but what does that have to do
with propagating the species
joy and pleasure have you ever made love
during the bee gees
like
it's a concert it's up to you
i have not made love to the bee gees
maybe i need to get on that nobody gets
too much heaven on my it's much harder
to go
[Music]
uh i always felt self-conscious making
love
with any music on really because it
always feels like
i i i just feel weirdly self-conscious
like whether it's like i would have
friends who would like get baked and
have sex to like pink floyd dark side of
the moon but then there's always the
buried
wizard of oz and get up at the same time
oh wow is that yeah i do pink floyd if
you stick it up to the wizard of oz it
fits really that might be fun okay yeah
try it yeah
yeah
sinking like who the [ __ ] are you yeah
but yeah do you did you do that
sometimes is that
mazzy star while having sex yeah okay if
i was dating someone you know but but
anything
more ambiguous uh or something where you
can't decipher the lyrics right if i
could hear i'm all out of love i'm gonna
i just i can't get hard my dick soft is
that's just the way it's gonna be my
dick is so soft
i can't make in love
with him
uh this is rain what year were was that
people magazine bachelors yeah that was
one of the top 50 bachelors a long time
ago probably 2005.
wow yeah 15 16 years ago yeah not
anymore
this is called [ __ ] talking with rayne
wilson this is rapid fire to wrap it up
yeah yeah i can't believe this has
already been over an hour
we've always been or not well what ryan
i'm happy to stay longer if you need me
i know this is amazing but ryan what
you've been taking so many notes what
the hell are you writing down i just
just write i just write it down just to
sort of uh keep track of like the things
that we talked about and uh if there's
anything the editor needs to know then
oh so this isn't like personal
no this no reigns
i don't believe anything he's just like
this is like for editing purposes this
is for editing purposes yeah and it's
also like there's something like oh this
is really interesting boom we're going
to put that in a clip when we put it on
right also i don't want to look i don't
know do you still do those animation
things
i don't but wasn't yours great yeah i
love that we should do another one maybe
i'll do another one with you okay great
i love those animation things i had this
animator out of like norway or something
that would do these animations and they
did one of of of rain and you paid just
a small amount of money it wasn't
incredibly expensive but uh you know i
was just like but you know what i want
to do those again i think that's a
really good idea can you make a note can
you you're welcome you've got a pad of
paper write it down right there you
write that down that's what this is for
uh rain wilson [ __ ] talking rapid fire
lovely patrons i love you out there
thanks for joining patreon and giving
the podcast a little more
uh raj favorite movie or show you
watched over the past year
uh we've been re uh
re-watching the sopranos and never seen
it i can't tell you how much delight
that show gives me i'm gonna watch just
gives me the tingles it is one of the
greatest comedies
ever made i'm not kidding okay the the
sense of humor the wry sense of humor
that runs throughout that show is
sensational
i have to watch it what am i doing what
are you doing with you i wish i could
put myself in your body and not ever
have seen the sopranos and watch it for
the first time it is so good okay you
know what we're gonna do
you and i are gonna start watching it
okay and like i'll go hey i'm on episode
three go oh i'm gonna catch up and we
could talk about it at least i'll have
somebody to watch it with okay
i'm in all right i've never seen it
either and you're really watching it's
awesome oh my god oh my god it's so good
the performances are crazy leanne p what
is something people would be surprised
to learn about you
um i'm a pretty good tennis player we've
been talking about playing tennis yeah
um but i don't think people would know
that and they'd be like oh there's a
portly middle-aged gentleman i was like
oh you couldn't he could play tennis he
could swing a racket i love it betsy d
did you enjoy interviewing billy eilish
yeah i totally did that was so cool it
was like oh look it's the most famous
person in the world and she's a huge
office fan and that's awesome yeah and
it was so cool because we interviewed
her in her childhood home and she was
still living there in a bedroom about
this size she's like the most famous
person in the world she was living in a
bedroom this size wow and her parents
little
bungalow in pasadena
jesus
um are you jealous of jenna fischer's
office show and do you wish you would
have done it that wasn't a question i
just asked that
did you just make that up and pretend to
read that off a piece of paper i'm not a
gel i wish them the very best i've i
guessed on the show a lot and put in my
input about the episodes i love jenna
and angela so much they are true they
are just the dearest sweetest kindest
people in the world funny
just amazing supportive
uh wish them all the luck in the world
but
that would be torture for me i'll show
up each week and go over the whole tv
show that i did i would do a lot of work
and there's a lot of work uh emily asks
who's been your favorite actor to work
with so far in your career the one that
you can name the one that comes to mind
i get a guy one
well i gotta go with steve carell right
i mean wow yeah
love him i love steve yeah um
steve's difficult to get to know i
wouldn't say that we're like intimate
buds but we text and he's a very sweet
guy but what a privilege and an honor to
have done
a hundred and
episodes with him
to improvise to watch him work i mean
he's one of the greatest actors
he's one of the great greats you're one
of the greats well
you're one of the greats i'm like
i'm like a b-plus
steve is like a a minus you know he's on
the next level
alice and janie i was doing this thing
on mom a recurring part where i got to
work where i was played her therapist
actually she's like steve she's like on
this next level actor she's like
very few that are on this first
ship yeah wow joey mack what was it like
working with rob zombie and your single
take away from that experience
um yeah a house of thousand corpses that
was my first kind of lead in a movie i
got we shot that in like 2 000. um it
was awesome take away from that
experience was uh
uh
hard
i i i what is the takeaway from that
speech i i loved that experience i mean
rob is an awesome dude he's going to be
doing the monsters
reboot that would be really cool i'm
definitely lining up to watch watching
that [ __ ] yeah
i didn't even look at my notes barely
this whole time except for those
questions
um you did very good you're very good at
this
i was nervous interviewing you why would
you well you're just incredibly smart
i'm not as smart as you now the people
are going to get mad because they're
like stop saying you're not smart i'm
just saying reigns a very bright guy
he's well read i'm not but i like to
listen to you and you have a lot of
insight and uh i don't think that i'm
smarter than you i think we're too very
in fact i don't think that people are
really
not smart i think that
you know we just we all have a balance
of you know it's like a d d character
you know you've got strength and
charisma and dexterity and you know roll
the dice to your flight dnd sure so
i think everyone but it all kind of adds
up to around the same level like i think
that humans are the same way so we have
you know we have emotional intelligence
and street smart street smarts and stuff
like that i think we're
but what do you think about ryan he
takes a lot of notes
i don't know my mind's not made up about
ryan i can't quite figure him out
there's not a lot of info bobby lee said
he looked like an eagle
oh because yeah the side angle the side
angle said you look like yeah
my secret agent name yeah i like that
this has been a real treat i really
appreciate you allowing me to be inside
of you again i hope you'll come back
maybe a year a couple years later uh i
love your podcast metaphysical milkshake
guys please
check it out i think you're gonna really
enjoy it it's uh it's worth watching and
listening you could watch or listen
either way i love being inside of you
thanks for being inside of me and uh
maybe we'll do this again in another two
or three years could we play tennis
let's promise to wait
i have texted you a few times it hasn't
worked out do i have your do i have your
number yeah yeah yeah it's happened are
you saying that i didn't text you back
no you did but you're like uh how about
thursday at 8 30 a.m i'm like no i can't
do thursday at 8 30 am frozen bomb here
hey rain are you texting me right now on
the air
yep there you go okay i love you thank
you okay thanks for having me bye
well you learn a lot you can learn a lot
from a rain
you sure can
yeah i really enjoyed the podcast hey
guys if you really enjoyed the podcast
today if you're a big rainey wilson fan
you never listen to the podcast please
subscribe give us a shot uh i think
you'll you'll dig it there's a lot of
great episodes in the can there's a lot
of episodes coming up um
and you know jason alexander's was a
real success that was really great
anthony michael hall was a success um so
you know go back listen to episodes and
um thank you to all our sponsors
and uh if you're interested hopefully
you guys like the sponsors and you could
uh you know
use the codes that we give you and
supports the podcast
um
thank you for listening
the handles are again if you want to
follow us at insideepodcast on the
instagram and the facebook and
insideipod if you want to get any merch
go to um in the inside of you online
store we've got lex luthor stuff
smallville stuff inside you stuff new
merch coming out so always be checking
on that and uh the band my band sunspin
go to sunspin.com you can get shirts and
mugs and other stuff we also have lunch
boxes there too but uh did you have a
good week ryan yeah man uh for
thanksgiving gear enough for
thanksgiving where are you going going
to uh my parents house in northern
california are you excited i am excited
i like going there does amanda like your
parents she does like my parents she
does yeah do you like your parents i
love my parents that's really nice yeah
you get along with them they were good
parents they showed you love and
affection they did
they did what's that like
it's nice man man that sounds groovy
it's so nice man it's so groovy uh no
it's just it's nice and uh i mean what's
kind of nice is that they are not in
like my childhood home so which would
have been in the valley in los angeles
but they moved up somewhere else and so
it's kind of like a vacation it's a
little vacation how many hours away uh
seven hour drive what's the address no
okay i actually don't know i'd love to
meet your family i just know where it is
you could tell you're just a really
genuine good guy i like you you're just
a really humble
person i'm very humble go on you while
you
are like to i'd love to meet the parents
the the two that are sort of responsible
for your uh for who you are today well
yeah well if they're if they're around
or you want to come to thanksgiving it's
not true i'm having a thanksgiving
dinner at my house but i would love to
meet them sometimes so make that happen
we'll make it happen we'll make it
happen uh thank you to all my patrons my
lovable patrons i just did a youtube
live with just my patrons that's part of
the perks of being a patron you can go
to patreon.com inside of you support the
podcast in other ways there's there's
merch there's uh i send boxes to folks
every few months um
we do youtube lives
discount on merch but more importantly
the patrons really
give back and i'm able to do this
podcast they just they give to the
podcast
whether it's a dollar a month or five
dollars a month and some are incredible
and give a lot more
i i really appreciate it and i want to
thank you
all of you
um for that again i'll be at the la
comic-con uh december 4th and 5th with
tom welling doing a smallville nights on
december 4th i hope you join us we have
a lot of fun
and uh why don't we read off the top
patrons these are the people who gave a
lot of uh a lot of coinage to the
podcast to keep this freaking thing
going thanks for the coinage thanks for
the coinage here we go
uh nancy d leah s trisha f sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h mama
lauren g nico p jerry w robert b jason w
kristen k amelia o allison l
raj c joshua d emily
uh what emily
f
s
cjp samantha m jennifer n stacy l
jen s jamal f janelle b kimberly e mike
eldon sopremo 99 more ramirez santiago m
sarah f chad w leanne p janine r maya p
matty s these guys are just
every one of you is just amazing belinda
n chris h dave h spider-man chase sheila
g brad d ray
charles ray charles yes ray h hi ray
tabitha t lillian a michelle k hello
michael s hello
talia m betsy d hi betsy claire
m laura l chad l rochelle nathan e
marion meg k janelle p trav l dan and
big stevie w angel m rhiannon c corey k
super sam coleman g dev nixon michelle a
liz i jeremy c andy t cody r sebastian k
gavinator david c
a few more here and uh thanks to all
these people as well john b brandy d
yvore camille s bono or bano or bonneau
the c the c joey m willie f christina e
adelaide n jeffrey m omar i lena n
design otg eugene and lee
leah
or eugene and lee
huh like a like a comedy l-e-a-h i think
it's leah yeah eugene and leah yeah
that's leah chris p nikki g cory ktb
patricia uh maria
n
maria ann uh i love all of you i can't
thank you enough for supporting this
podcast and keeping it going i never
thought i'd be doing 180 something
podcasts i thought i would quit after
three and no one's gonna listen i stuck
with it you stuck with me and i
appreciate it more than you possibly
know um from myself michael rosenbaum
here in the hollywood hills of
california along with ryan taylor's in
the hollywood hills
that's right a little way to the camera
we love you thank you so much for uh
making me a part of your day and and
giving me the time and listening and
supporting the podcast thank you for
allowing me to be in each inside
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you have a
glorious week be good to yourself um and
much love ryan anything that's it that's
it that's all we got yeah thanks guys
[Music]
you